-I wanted to ask you because you
have something
in common with
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
He actually wrote an episode of
"Veronica Mars"?
-He did.
We're marshmallows, guys.
He's a marshmallow.
-Really?
-Yes.
He is a spectacular writer.
For anyone who hasn't read
anything he's written,
I highly, highly recommend you
seek it out.
He's got such
a great perspective,
he's such an awesome writer.
And during the reboot at Hulu,
he, like, submitted to be
a writer and Rob Thomas,
our creator, like, freaked out.
-Yeah, like, "Wait, Kareem
watches 'Veronica Mars'?
He likes us?"
-We were like, "what?"
And he wrote
a spectacular episode.
So we worked together.
-How cool is that?
I love that.
-Pretty cool.
-I want to get to the book.
Congrats on this.
-Thank you.
-It's awesome.
This weekend was Father's Day,
and I know Dax,
your husband, Dax Shepard,
very, very funny individual.
I love him.
-Yeah. He's a stud.
-He's a stud.
-He's funny,
but he's also a stud.
-He is a stud.
-Yeah.
-When I knew him, he was always
in shape, but now he's jacked.
-He is -- He took COVID
very seriously.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. He was --
-He took it as an opportunity
to just lift.
-Lift so much.
-Yeah.
-He lifts all the time.
He loves muscles.
It's really cute.
-But he has his own gym, right?
-He has his own gym.
And that's -- what's funny --
well, ironic, is he was
out of town for Mother's Day,
and I was out of town
for Father's Day,
so we kind of blew it.
But on Saturday we got him
out of the house.
His buddy, like, took him
somewhere.
And my girls and I -- He has
a gym, which is our garage.
And it is not new.
And he calls it Black Mold
Paradise because he has,
for about the last year
and a half, been challenging
The Rock publicly to, like,
I guess workout battles?
[ Laughter ]
-Is that a thing?
-I guess.
Like, lifting challenges maybe?
It's not like a fight.
He's not dumb. He doesn't want
to fight The Rock.
He posts on Instagram a lot
like, "Bring it on, Dwayne."
Because he has Iron Paradise,
which is this beautiful gym.
-Oh, The Rock's gym is
unbelievable.
And he doesn't let anyone work
out there.
-He doesn't?
-No, no, it's, like, secret.
-Oh, then this is
a losing battle for Dax.
Well, I think what Dax is trying
to do is invite him
to Black Mold Paradise, which is
about the size of this stage.
-Black Mold Paradise?
-Black Mold Paradise, yeah.
'Cause there's a little --
There's some creepy crawlies
in the corners.
-Yeah, there's something growing
in there.
-But what he calls it --
his full name for the gym is
Dan Gainz -- with a Z --
Dan Gainz Beef Haus
#blackmoldparadise.
By the way, he uses this hashtag
on Instagram all the time.
-And it makes no sense. No one
knows what he's talking about.
-Nobody knows what it is.
He doesn't care.
-He doesn't care.
-No, he doesn't care.
-Dan Gainz --
-Dan Gainz -- he calls himself
Dan for, like, takeout 'cause
nobody knows what Dax is.
-Yeah, they don't recognize that
as a name.
-Right, and they're like,
"Sure, Zack."
And he's like,
"I'll just say Dan."
Dan Gainz Beef Haus
#blackmoldparadise.
So for Father's Day, we got him
out of the house.
And my girls and I went in there
and we spray-painted
Dan Gainz Beef Haus
#blackmoldparadise.
And, like, decorated with
acrylic markers all over
the inside of his gym to cover
up all the black mold.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's a picture right here.
-Yeah.
-Dan Gainz Beef Haus.
-Beef Haus.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It almost seems like German.
-So, I got, like,
vinyl stencils.
That's the cool thing about
knowing prop masters
from, like, film and TV work.
-Yeah, we're lucky.
-You can be like,
"Can I get a vinyl stencil,
like 12 inches by 9 feet?"
And they're like, "Absolutely."
-I want to see, like --
He should make hot dogs.
-I'm sure he would not have
a problem with it.
-[ German accent ] Beef Haus.
-When I met him, he had
a hot dog maker that was like
half the size of this table,
like, in the kitchen.
-And I was like --
-Dax, I will -- I will take that
from you, Dax.
-We've already given it away.
-You already gave it away?
-Yeah, we gave it to
Ryan Hansen.
It still comes out
once in a while,
but it's not in my kitchen.
[ Laughter ]
-I have some things, where,
yeah, my wife was like,
"Yeah, we're good with that
if you want to give it
to your friend or something."
Why don't you want
this wall-sized poster
of the Beastie Boys?"
[ Laughter ]
"It's time to move on, bud."
-Sometimes you just gotta --
-Yeah.
My buddy gave me this thing
I still have in my office.
He was like --
'Cause I love Buddy Holly.
It's just a weird two things.
I love Buddy Holly,
and I also love stained glass.
-Okay.
-And I don't know why it just
came up, and he's like,
"You love stained glass."
And he said something like,
"Do you like Buddy Holly?"
And I go, "I do actually."
He goes, "I have a stained-Glass
portrait of Buddy Holly..."
[ Laughter ]
"...that my wife is like,
'there's no way we're
keeping this
in the living room.'"
So I go, "I will borrow it,
and whenever you need it back,
I will hang it in my office."
And it's been in my office
since "Late Night."
Neal Brennan, if you need it
back, I have it.
-Oh, my God.
Neal, you got rid of that?
-No, yeah, it's pretty --
It's pretty magical, yeah.
-That's amazing. Sometimes you
inherit some good stuff.
-Yeah, I like it.
I want to talk about
your new book.
Congrats on this, by the way.
-Thank you.
-"The World Needs
More Purple Schools."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Out tomorrow.
Your first book,
"The World Needs
More Purple People,"
was an instant "New York Times"
best seller.
Right to number one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-It's great. I love the art.
I love the --
I love all of the, uh --
-There's a lot of boogers in it.
-There's boogers in it?
-There was boogers
in the first one.
There's boogers
in this one, guys.
-Yeah, it'll make kids laugh
and kids happy and make --
-Hopefully better people too.
Hopefully good people.
-It'll make people think
and make good people,
which is what we want.
That's the point.
-That was kind of the goal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the point.
Well, 'cause, yeah, in the first
one, we identified these
five principles we thought
were -- it was like, we wrote
the first one when the world was
arguing.
Remember when, like, everyone
was arguing about everything,
and it was the only thing
everybody wanted to do?
It's, like, died down a little
bit, but we still love to argue.
And so, we were like, "What if
we come up with these
purple principles that made
being nice and responsible
and a good listener cool?"
So we were like, "purple people,
they ask great questions.
They laugh a lot.
They work hard.
They use their voice,
and they listen.
And they -- Just be you.
Because you're the --"
We like to say, "Because you're
the only you we've got."
-Yeah, that is true.
[ Audience aws ]
[ Applause ]
I love that.
And there's a little Easter egg
in here,
a tiny nod to "Frozen,"
which I like.
And you're like --
Can we just see there?
In a little -- "Let it go."
-"And then she said,
'Let it go, let it go.'"
-Yes! Exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then there's the boogers!
[ Laughter ]
-There are boogers there, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Tough segue right into
"Frozen."
-True.
-You know, I love "Frozen II."
-Thank you.
-I almost liked it
maybe better -- Can I say that?
-Of course you can.
You can say whatever you want.
-That's true, I can.
-Yeah.
-It's your show.
-It is my show.
I did enjoy "Frozen," but
"Frozen II" kind of -- great.
"Frozen 3," can we announce
anything?
-I would like
to officially announce --
[ Drumroll ]
With zero authority,
"Frozen 3."
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Please bear in mind I did say
"zero authority"
'cause I can't do that.
-Yeah, you can't announce it.
-I'm not -- I can't do that.
No, I'm not in charge.
-But there could be something
maybe in the works
and maybe happening, maybe.
-Well, you know, I'm --
I'll keep it mysterious.
But I know Idina recently said
she would do it,
And I feel like
if we're all in...
-We're all in.
-What are we waiting for?
-Come on, we want it.
-We want it. Let's do it.
-Kristen Bell.
"The World Needs
More Purple Schools"
is available tomorrow!